eyes they needed he was relentless
in teaching his students to refuse to
let socioeconomic obstacles
block their dreams and their progress
and so it was no surprise that he was
named the state's youngest
school principal a few short years after
he started teaching
as principal it also won't surprise you
to know that he was one of those
principals that knew
every kid's name knew every kid's story
he dressed up as a conductor for polar
express day he performed with the
students at holiday
concerts and he relentlessly built a
community of teachers
students and parents he led by example
and so the promotions kept coming he
tackled teacher diversity as assistant
superintendent in meriden he
championed the cause of replacing
draconian exclusionary school discipline
policies with restorative justice
practices
and as has been mentioned as our state's
commissioner he led
the effort to reopen connecticut's
schools earlier than most
people thought was possible and he did
it in a way
that didn't divide teachers from
students
and parents miguel cardona keeps getting
asked to do bigger things for
a reason he has a servant's heart
an immovable moral compass a refusal to
take no for an answer
and a unique talent for consensus
building something that will be
essential in this job he's going to make
a great secretary of education and i'm
so glad to join
senator blumenthal in expressing
connecticut's pride and support for him
today
thank you senator murphy dr cardona
welcome thank you so much for being here
today
we are looking forward now to hearing
from you so you can begin
your testimony thank you
chair murray ranking member burr
distinguished members of the committee
it's an honor to appear before you today
as the president's nominee
to serve as secretary of education thank
you senator blumenthal
and senator murphy for your kind words
and support
soy miguel caldona husband of marissa
and proud father of miguel junior and
celine
son of hector and sierra cardona and
brother to hector jr
and marisol their role in my life has
shaped my preparation for today
today's hearing as much as any degree or
professional experience i've had
while the pandemic has prevented them
from all of them from joining me in the
room today
i carry their presence in every word i
speak we're here today in the midst
of one of the most challenging school
years in american history
for far too many of our students this
year has piled on crisis after crisis
as a parent and as an educator i've
lived those challenges alongside
millions of families the burden on
educators and families has been
tremendous
taking a toll on the mental health and
well-being of our children
our parents our educators and staff
fewer students started college this fall
and those declines were most striking at
community colleges
institutions that have long served as
entry points to higher education
and economic mobility for so many
our nation's educational challenges
didn't begin with the pandemic
but it has exacerbated inequities in our
educational system
these inequities will endure and they'll
prevent the potential of this
country unless tackled head on
and it is so it is and so it's our
responsibility
and it would be my greatest privilege if
confirmed
to forge opportunity out of this crisis
as americans we've always risen to the
challenge to solve problems
and create a brighter future for our
students this was true for my family
when
my parents my grandparents avelino and
maria cardona
and hermana muniz traveled from the
beautiful city of aguada puerto rico
to find new opportunities in the silver
city of meredith connecticut
it was true when my parents hector and
sarah taught me to dream big
and to aim high their own hard work
empowered me to expand my horizons and
become the first in my family to
graduate college
while we didn't always have a lot of
material possessions i was born rich
this perseverance turned into gratitude
when i became a teacher
a principal a district leader in the
very same community
that gave me so much as a child
for me education opened doors
that is the power and the promise of
america
but it's not a promise kept for every
student
if i am fortunate enough to be confirmed
i will work tirelessly
to make sure our education system is a
door to opportunity
a great equalizer for every student
we will work to reopen schools safely so
that students can return to classrooms
we will remove silos in education
sharing our breakthroughs and successes
throughout our country and cultivating
schools and colleges as places
of innovation we will make sure
that when students graduate from high
school they have college
and career pathways to good futures
we will make sure we will make college
accessible to every student who seeks
opportunity
through education including
strengthening this nation's
best kept secret community colleges
we will ensure that dedicated teachers
para educators principals
superintendents and committed higher
education faculty
are recognized for their great
contribution to this country
and we will boldly address educational
inequities
head on and hold ourselves accountable
for providing equitable outcomes
from pre-kindergarten through college
and into adult learning
investing in public education change
changes lives
and it saves lives i've seen it and i've
lived it
and i know our challenges ahead are
problems that we can
overcome together as the saying in
spanish goes
in unity there is strength we gain
strength
from joining together and like our
schools
we gain strength when we create a
culture of
community that is why you've confirmed
i look forward to sitting at the table
with the vast diverse community of
people who have a stake in education
students parents teachers
caregivers advocates and state
local and tribal leaders and the
dedicated career staff
at the department their voices matter
i can think of no higher calling than
working to build a better
more equal future for the next
generation
i have the same dreams for all of the
students in our country as i do
for my own angelito and celine
i'm grateful for the chance to take on
this responsibility and i'm grateful
for your time today i'm grateful to
president biden
and vice president harris for placing
their trust in me
in closing as your nominee
i am first a husband of a family school
liaison
a father of two public high schoolers an
educator
and most importantly a student advocate
if confirmed i look forward to getting
to work on behalf of
all students in working with you to
build a future
of promise and opportunity for the next
generation
thank you and i look forward to
answering any questions you may have
dr cardona thank you very much we all
appreciate that
we will now begin a round of five minute
questions
and i would just ask my colleagues to
keep track of your clock if you would
stay within those five minutes so we can
respect everyone's time
and i am very happy to stay if anyone
has additional questions if we want a
second round for anyone
dr cardona um the the coven 19 pandemic
is really having a profound
impact on students abrupt school
closures
lack of access to high quality remote
learning or
a conducive learning environment
educator layoffs and general chaos and
confusion
has really severely disrupted student
learning
so we have a big job ahead of us to help
support our students
our educators and our schools respond to
and recover from this pandemic
and that starts with providing schools
and colleges with the resources
they need to reopen safely for in-person
learning
and i was pleased to see president
biden's plan called for significantly
more funding
it also demands strong federal
leadership to accomplish that goal
but we have a long road ahead dr cardona
as connecticut's
commissioner of education you've been
working every day for the past year
to address the needs of students and
their families during this pandemic
talk to us about how your experience in
connecticut
informs your work as secretary of
education
in navigating the coven 19 response
thank you for the question uh senator
murray
you know i want to acknowledge the fact
that as a country we are experiencing
some trauma together
and uh serving as
commissioner of education in connecticut
has provided the opportunity for
me to be in a position to help lead with
amazing
partners at the agency and throughout
the state in the reopening of our
schools
through these last 10 months i've been
able to listen to
parents students educators
and we all want to make sure we can get
our students back into school safely
some of the strategies that we took in
connecticut that were very clear were
to make sure that we relied very closely
on the science
we partnered with our public health
experts in the state
and and created a system of
communication that was regular
and intentional we were open and
transparent with what we knew
and we made sure that we partnered with
our health experts to put out very clear
guidance
early on to make sure that
the mitigation strategies were very
clear to make sure that
we talked about how to safely reopen
schools and how to provide the students
the
access to learning if they had to learn
remotely
we partnered together and i look forward
to if if
i'm fortunate enough to serve as
secretary of education to bring that
same mentality of partnership
and clear communication to help recover
our public education and reopen our
schools
thank you very much you know one of my
greatest concerns about the pandemic's
impact
on students is learning loss
particularly for students who
face systemic barriers including
students of color
students from families with low incomes
lgbtqia students
students with disabilities and english
learners and the pandemic has really
further widened the achievement gaps in
this country
so dr cardona if you're confirmed as
secretary
how would you support states and school
districts
in identifying and addressing learning
loss
among all students again thank you for
that question
you know this this learning loss is
is something that we're all grappling
with but before i get into that i want
to acknowledge
our students have shown us a level of
resilience that i don't think we've ever
seen in history before
our students have really risen to the
occasion and really um
adapted in ways that are inspiring to me
as an educator and as a father
but we know that especially in many
communities that don't have great
resources
students have not had access to quality
learning
or have had interrupted learning so we
have to make sure that
we identify those practices that we know
are effective at meeting students where
they are
we know that with proper support and
funding
we can offer extended learning
opportunities for students
extended summer school options to help
students recover some of that loss
and we have to make sure that the
materials that we put in front of our
students are high quality materials
so that our students are able to benefit
the most from any intervention
or access to learning that they get
moving forward we need to do this not
only
by providing strong remote and and
quality materials there but ensuring
that we're doing everything in our power
to safely reopen schools
there is no substitute for a classroom
experience for our students
being in front of their teacher there is
no substitute for that so we have to do
everything we can to safely reopen
schools
in a manner that gets a student back
into their learning environment
thank you very much i will turn the
questions over to dr
senator burt at this point senator thank
you madam chairman you can call me
doctor if you'd like to
yeah sorry
um dr cardona again
welcome to you and to your family on
january 12th
the fairfax education association in
virginia
tweeted at you that schools should not
reopen
until all staff and students had
received a vaccine
do you agree with the fairfax education
association on this
thank you senator you know i recognize
the frustration and distrust and and
fear that that is out there and if
confirmed as secretary of education i'll
do everything in my power
to make sure that our rollout strategy
for reopening schools includes
uh communication on how to safely reopen
schools
and i think that needs to include
increased surveillance
testing for our educators and a
prioritization of our educators for
vaccination
but just to be clear
to safely open a school and to
safely keep a school open
it doesn't require that 100 percent of
the
participants be vaccinated to accomplish
that
we have examples and i know in
connecticut we have many examples but we
have great examples throughout our
country of schools that are able to
reopen safely
and do so while following mitigation
strategies
um while i recognize that that is the
case i do believe that
making sure surveillance testing is
something that we focus on as well
should teachers be prioritized for
vaccination
and when
i use the term teachers
does that include public and private
school teachers together
i use the term educators there's so many
members of the school community that
uh contribute to making the school
successful so uh
our educators should be prioritized for
uh vaccination rollout uh especially as
we
we work to maintain our schools open
and we have to keep in mind also that
reopening schools is not just about
the next month or two if we want to keep
them reopened we have to make sure that
we're
properly testing our teachers and
educators and
um prioritizing them for vaccination
keeping an eye on the variance and the
different
changes that might take place i think it
is a priority to provide uh
testing and vaccination for our
educators and when you
use the term educators you're not
separating between public and private
all education all educators thank you
states like connecticut
may want to pursue testing this year
just to have some data to understand
the learning loss problem they have on
their hands
but due to the validity and reliability
issues of conducting testing remotely
and in hybrid situations testing experts
say that the scores may not
even be comparable to scores from before
or
after cobit 19. it really doesn't seem
fair to include test scores and schools
performance accountability measures
as required under the essay in
state plans do you plan to waive the
need to include scores in school
accountability for
state plans this year thank you for the
question sir and i know that
not only kova testing but assessments
are an issue of
of concern and a great debate i speak to
you now as a nominee obviously i have
not had any role in any policy
development
to this point i can speak to you from
the role of a commissioner
i know that validity of testing is
critically important as a school
principal i remember
making sure that assessment data was
looked at only if it
was valid and reliable with that said
i don't think i'm in favor of a
what you called earlier one size fits
all if the conditions under cover 19
prevent a student from being in school
in person i don't think we need to be
bringing students in
just to test them on a standardized test
i don't think that makes any sense
with that said i do feel sir that if we
don't assess where our students are
and their level of performance it's
going to be difficult for us to provide
some
targeted support and our resource
allocation in a manner that
can best support the closing of the gaps
that have been exacerbated through this
pandemic do you feel that states should
be able to decide whether they
incorporate standardized testing
this year given the circumstances of
pandemic
i feel that states should not only have
an opportunity to weigh in on
how they plan on implementing and what's
best for their students
but also the accountability measures and
whether or not those
assessments should really be tied into
any accountability measures
as well doctor i thank you madam
chairman i
return the time right senator casey
madam chair thanks very much i
appreciate this opportunity to
ask dr cardona a question but i wanted
to start by
commending our new chair uh senator
murray and the ranking member senator
burr for the way they opened this
hearing today
we're grateful for the for their awards
today and dr cardona i want to start by
commending you
for the achievements uh in your life
today i'm not sure there are many if any
secretaries of education who have served
as
not only a fourth grade teacher but also
a principal as well as an assistant
superintendent and then finally as
education commissioner so
you're not only well qualified but i
think your story is a great
american story of hard work and
sacrifice
and we're grateful that you're willing
to put yourself forward for
additional public service i'm going to
try to get to two issues
the first will take a little longer
because it's a particular issue
that affects students with disabilities
and the second is a question about early
learning but let me start with the
question regarding students with
disabilities in this unique
issue students with disabilities face
significant barriers to entering
and completing post-secondary education
federally funded research found that
students with learning disabilities
attend college
at half the rate of their peers without
who don't have disabilities and are less
likely
to come to complete their programs few
students were told it's about one in
four
with learning disabilities inform their
colleagues that they have a disability
and many high school students with
disabilities and their parents
find the process to secure both
accommodations
and services in colleges and both
difficult and unclear
i've got legislation with senator
cassidy that would ease the transition
by among other things ensuring
institutions of higher education
make information about requesting uh
an accommodation both or transparent for
both the
prospective student as well as current
students
and also this legislation would ensure
that proof of a disability
in k-12 education is sufficient to
receive accommodations
in higher education settings president
biden's education agenda indicated he
would increase
funding for post-secondary programs
that support students with disabilities
and and will direct the department of
education to provide guidance
to those post-secondary programs so i
guess the two-part question here is
how will you ensure that students with
disabilities have increased
access to post-secondary education
and second how will you make sure that
those
higher education institutions are
prepared to support
and provide services to students with
disabilities
thank you for the question senator i do
acknowledge that
you know the dream of higher education
or the goal of higher education is one
that we have to expand in our country
and it's one that i'm committed to
serving and working with you and others
to
to learn more about and see how we can
at the agency have confirmed
support that work helping students
gain access to higher education is a
process that does require
coordination and collaboration with our
pre-k-12 systems and our higher
education
systems clarity and communication and
expectations
and really just a culture of not only
looking at
these students as students with
disabilities but looking at them as
students with assets
students with great abilities who have
to learn a certain way or or
require accommodations so i think that
cultural shift is
a prerequisite to any technical
strategies with that said
our agency would be poised to not only
look for best practices across our
country of where they're doing it right
and where
they're finding success and sharing
those best practices but also ensuring
that
we're looking at how these universities
are what outcomes are they're getting
uh when serving students with
disabilities making sure that we're
partnering with them but also
keeping an eye on how our students with
disabilities are fairing in these uh
colleges so
something that i'm pretty passionate
about as well and i look forward to
working with you and others to learn
more about it and see how
we can support thank you very much and i
know i'm short on time but i'll i'll
just uh maybe i'll
submit a longer question for the record
but the question pertains to early
education i like to say that
if kids learn more now they're going to
earn more later i think all the evidence
shows that
i will submit a question regarding
expanding access to early learning
uh early care and learning and also
about the coordination between and among
federal government agencies and programs
uh but now that i'm down to six seconds
i'll leave that for a
written question possibly in the second
round but i know you have a
broad experience in early learning and
we'll we'll speak to that a little later
thank you doctor thank you look forward
to it
thank you senator casey uh we will turn
to senator collins
thank you madam chairman i look forward
to working with you
and ranking member burr this year
dr cardona i want to thank you for
sharing your inspiring
story with us today i think it
is a perfect role model for so many
children in this country
i also appreciate the time that you took
to meet with me and i want to
bring up two issues that we touched on
in those meetings there is a lot of
focus
and understandably so in this country
on low-income children in large
urban schools but we also have
a lot of low-income children in rural
schools
along with former senator ken conrad
i authored the rural education
achievement program known as reap and in
2015
that program was reauthorized it is
the only direct federal support
for small rural low-income
schools for example island schools
off the coast of maine have used it to
buy technology
to connect their students and enrich
their learning
experience this program
is really vital yet last year
the department announced changes in the
formula
that was used to determine eligibility
for
the re program the result was that it
would have
abruptly eliminated funding
for more than 100 rural
low-income school districts in the state
of maine
when we talked one-on-one i went into
more detail
about the devastating impact of this
i'm seeking today as you testify
your commitment to work with me to
resolve the formula issues so that the
rural
low-income students across our country
it wasn't just in maine
that this eligibility change
had this effect will receive the funding
that the reap program envisioned
thank you senator for for the question
uh i recognize and and
through the great conversation i had
with you the the challenges that rural
communities face and
i commit to looking at this very closely
if confirmed and working with you
and others to learn more about how these
issues in rural communities are
really need more attention i'll tell you
during the pandemic
in a small state like connecticut we
found that our rural communities
were facing challenges that were
different than urban centers
and they were equally as important
connectivity was an issue
and accessing high quality content is
only dependent on how well your signal
is
so i recall those conversations with uh
parents and and students and educators
in the rural communities and i recognize
with conversat
after the conversation with you and
others the importance that this has in
our country not only with the pandemic
but past the pandemic making sure that
the needs of our students in rural
communities
are being met i look forward to learning
more about it
from you and your colleagues but also
serving
uh to do the best we can as the agency
to make sure we're meeting the needs of
those learners as well
thank you the second issue i want to
bring up
has to do with the trio programs which i
am a big supporter of
which help first generation
disadvantaged students
pursue higher education
and there are many
incredibly dedicated people at the
department of education
let me make that clear but let me tell
you what happened
a few years ago the department
made a very abrupt bureaucratic decision
really embodies
the worst of bureaucracy that denied
funding to an upward bound program
in my state on the basis
of a formatting problem
in the application and this was
a spacing problem instead of being
double spaced
in a particular graph it was one and a
half
spaces that's how minor and
the university of maine at prescott was
not given an opportunity
to correct this well the result
of this would have been that more than
900
students would have been denied access
to the upward bound program over a
five-year
program of the grant and
i worked with other senators we senator
murray was one who also signed the
letter
senator tester there were many senators
on both sides of the aisle
we sent three letters to the department
saying
this is ridiculous this is not
the format is not dictated by law
this is arbitrary in the case of maine's
application it was in
a graph that it was included in a
65-page
application and yet it wasn't even
reviewed for the merits
well the department only changed
course after i added language to the
appropriations bill
it should not have taken
legislative language in an
appropriations bill to get the
department
to prioritize the needs of disadvantaged
students
participating in the upward bound
program
over bureaucratic formatting
errors and i would just ask
again for your commitment to make sure
that we take a more common sense
approach and always remember that the
students come first
thank you senator i commit not only to a
strong partnership and
and uh ability to work with you and
i also want to commit if confirmed that
our agency will be a service agency
making sure that our students needs are
at the forefront
thank you thank you senator collins uh
senator warren
thank you madam chair and dr cardona
congratulations on your nomination
you were a first generation college
student
and for you and for me an affordable
college education
opened a million doors but today
students face a very different situation
so i want to talk with you today
about student debt i know you know these
facts but i think it helps
everyone if we can just talk about them
for a few minutes
so about 43 million people that's
one in five adults in america
have federal student loan debt is that
right that is right
good and this debt adds up to more than
about a trillion and a half dollars
now about 40 percent of the people with
student loan debt
do not have a college degree can you
just say a word
about what that means for them well what
it means is that
because they don't have the college
degree maybe they don't have the income
potential that they would have had if
they had the degree and
and paying these bills will be a a
larger task and probably a longer
process
so i said that uh students that are
not able to graduate and uh probably
would have their income affected because
they weren't able to graduate and get
the income
potential earning potential that they
would have had if they did and
they're probably in greater debt and it
may be more of a challenge to pay off
their debt
we may have lost senator warren is she
did we lose her video
fatty i think we did lose uh okay we i i
believe
we've lost senator warren we'll try and
get back to you um when you're
is she there
warren let's see if we can fix that and
we will move to senator paul and then
go back to her okay
the office of civil rights sent a letter
to connecticut
saying that boys can't compete with
girls in
in sports or we should be forced to
allow
boys to compete in girls sports uh if
you're
confirmed will you enforce that office
of civil rights opinion
hello senator uh thank you for the
question i understand that there are
a lot of concerns about that uh it's
it's
if confirmed it's my responsibility and
my uh privilege to make sure that we're
following uh
our civil rights of all students and
that includes uh activities that
they may engage in in high school or in
athletics what do you think in general
about boys running in
girls trackmates like they've been doing
in connecticut
i think that it's critically important
to educated
education systems and educators respect
the rights of all
students including students who are
transgender um and
that they are afforded the opportunities
that every other student has to
participate in extracurricular activity
does it bother you that like the top
20 of boys running in track meets beat
all of the girls in the state and that
it
you know would you know completely
destroy girls athletics the girls are
being pushed out
um they don't make the finals in the
state meet they don't get college
scholarships
they're really detrimental to girls
sports do you worry about having boys
running girls track meets
you know i i recognize and appreciate
the concerns
um and the frustrations that are
expressed i've as commissioner of
education
have had conversations with families uh
who have felt
the way you just described it in
families of uh students who are
transgender
so i understand that this is a challenge
i look forward to working with you and
others to
do you think it's fair you gotta have
boys running in the girls track mate
i think it's appropriate for i think
it's it's the legal responsibility of
schools to provide opportunities for
students to uh
participativities and this includes
students who are transgender
so you don't have a problem then with
boys running in the girls track meet
swimming